hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that aims to put the science
back into science fiction but first I
wanted to take a minute to just talk
about excuse me no I don't think this is
universal we wanted Rick well look at
what we have here folks it seems like
some rogue visitors may have just opened
up a transdimensional gateway into my
living room can I help you uh we're
looking for dimension c-130 - you
wouldn't happen to know where that is
located
sorry guys our universes classification
number is D 27:31 but while we're on the
topic you're technically using the word
dimension incorrectly you see dimensions
define elements of physical space I'm
sure you're familiar with the elements
of height with potentially depth the hue
seem to be just as flat as I am whereas
oh we got a talker here you know what
just just stop don't point that at me
I'm just trying to help you guys sorry
not sorry for trying to be helpful oh my
god shut up this guy never stops talking
just just just just just get out of the
spaceship oh and by the way no one over
the age of 7 thinks the animatronics are
scary either so so take that well that
was rude now the question is how do I
get home Oh Rick and Morty's portal gun
shoot this thing at any surface and you
open up a green circular portal to
practically any location oh here I come
second time's the charm
this has got to be just a coincidence
okay
it does not take a big brain to Rick and
Morty fan to understand that this thing
might be a little bit broken so I guess
I gotta figure out how this thing works
but how do you fix a piece of technology
like this I mean the science contained
in this thing is so sought after that
the Galactic Federation infiltrated
Rick's brain in the hopes of uncovering
its secrets I guess in that respect then
I'm a little like the Galactic
Federation because today is gonna be all
about me trying to figure out how Rick's
portal gun actually works let's start by
picking apart what we do know about the
portal gun our first real glimpse into
the detailed workings of the portal gun
happens during the audience's first
encounter with the council of ricks
where we learn that much like your
internet browser the portal gun keeps a
detailed list of all the locations its
users visited come on don't look at
another man's portal gun history we all
go to weird places later in the series
and elsewhere in the Citadel we learned
that the portal gun relies on some sort
of fluid I want a portal gun with enough
fluid to take me off this prison a fluid
that if replaced with an incorrect
bootleg tends to create portals with
some unfortunate side effects this fluid
may in some ways be connected to the
number of times that the gun can
actually be used to create portals in
both the show's pilot episode as well as
the episode get schwifty rick outright
mentions it having a limited charge I
spent so much time there my
interdimensional portal device it's got
no charge left there's only so much
charge left in this thing if we portal
home from here and back we're not gonna
have enough charge left to get offworld
then again it could all be lies because
Rick is lazy about the charge you were
just being lazy see told you but by far
the most interesting property of the
portal gun is its ability to open
portals to well just about anywhere not
just within our own universe but between
universes Rick seems to use his portal
gun to travel within the universe pretty
frequently for example in the episode
raising desorbs orb Rick and summer used
the portal gun to teleport to the planet
gazorpazorp but after the portal gun
gets smashed on the planet they're
forced to use
spaceship to travel back to earth this
proves that gazorpazorp and earth are in
the same universe far apart though they
may be but throughout the series various
Rick's use their respective portal guns
to visit other parallel universes and
it's that second property that seems to
set Rick's portal gun apart from all the
other existing Galactic Federation
technology we get confirmation of this
in the season 3 premiere Rick shank
redemption when it's revealed that the
Federation is using a brain eliezer on
Rick to discover the secrets of
interdimensional travel should we go
straight to the moment I discovered
interdimensional travel whoa your little
flappy doodles are twitching again the
key word here is interdimensional
interdimensional travel is travel
between dimensions while intron
dimensional travel would be travel
within a dimension the Galactic
Federation already has teleporter
technology it's the blue portal that we
see in the pilot episode what they want
is the ability to travel to other
universes the green portal technology
and heck life wouldn't they want this
when you open up one of these babies
literally anything can fall out of them
you know I remember when that used to be
fun see hey that diet I was on it seemed
to be working
wait a minute you you look familiar
you're Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I uh I would love to
continue this totally real conversation
that is in no way a forced narrative
construct to explain your presence on
the show right now but you see I have a
malfunctioning portal gun here that I
need to repair in order to get home you
think you could help me out here Neil
sure but only for a short while my
quantum stability in this universe is
weak and getting weaker by the minute
no is that really true nah it's just a
line I use to get out of conversations
that are running too long Matt that how
did you know my name
narrative construct remember Yeah right
now if you hope to use those portals to
get back home the first thing you have
to do is to clarify whether you're
invoking a true multiverse or the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics the many-worlds interpretation
asserts that whenever an event occurs
that could have multiple outcomes the
universe branches into as many copies as
are necessary to enable all outcomes at
the same time Oh kind of like in that
episode of Rick and Morty
Rick potion number nine which shows our
dynamic duo entering new universes that
are extremely similar to their own in
this case they escaped from their
original
universe when rick is unable to cure a
genetic epidemic by going into a brand
new universe where rick does manage to
create the cure two worlds branched out
from one core decision correct but only
if you needed it to explain that one
scene in rick potion number nine but it
wouldn't explain lizard morty or hammer
head morty you get that from the
multiverse hypothesis which states that
there are many perhaps infinitely many
big bangs that each started their own
universes they all coexist and because
they each had their own beginning they
could have completely different laws of
physics or completely different Morty's
as opposed to many worlds where you're
always starting with the same base rules
and regulations so well the many-worlds
interpretation could explain similar
earth-like worlds like we see in rick
potion it wouldn't explain some of the
other universes that we see in the show
like pizzas that sit in chairs and use
their phones to order people or phones
that sit on pizza and use their people
to order chairs or chairs who sit on
people and use their pizzas to order
phones right exactly and in the
multiverse hypothesis each of those
parallel universes coexist with our own
universe but since the laws of physics
can be different it would be extremely
dangerous to visit them the molecular
forces that hold your body together
could be compromised in the presence of
different physical laws
you might just spontaneously collapse
into a pile of goo so does that mean
rick's portal gun is all fiction and no
science we'll never be able to visit
alternate universes well we can't say
it's impossible to reach other universes
because we're limited by our own
understanding of the laws of physics
last year you might have seen the
headline scientists are attempting to
open portal to a parallel universe
just some over-the-top clickbait right
clickable yes over-the-top
no it's less step through a gate into an
evil alternative universe where there
copies of us with evil mustaches and
more like set up a magnetic field to see
if we can capture neutrons that had
briefly traveled through an alternative
universe what does that even mean though
well there are a lot of strange things
going on in our universe that might
possibly be explained by the existence
of other universes
in this particular
case the scientists are looking at why
certain neutrons are decaying at
different speeds than expected so it may
be possible to enter alternate universes
but how I'm sorry Matt Pat but my
quantum state is weakening good bye good
bye
what adapter I hate when quantum states
give bad reception stupid flat Pat why
did you ask the important questions
first
curse my propensity for a long gating
watch time all right I guess that means
I got to solve this one myself unless
the portal gun has one more charge in at
show me Bill Nye no okay all right what
would this be how would portal guns work
it's got to be wormholes right I mean in
science fiction it is always wormholes
and honestly it's something that we
already see consistently throughout this
series in the world leaderly conspiracy
Rick and Jerry's trip back to earth
involves a hop through a large ship
sized wormhole when I say trip and
really mean trip then in the more recent
episode never ricky morty we briefly see
rick working in a lab and in the
background there's a blackboard that has
a diagram of various wormholes that has
got to be yet see one of the things that
albert einstein changed about our
understanding is that space and time are
bendy and inc machine sorry
no stay focused matt or universe can be
conceived of like a large flat flexible
plane if that sheet were bent in the
right way it would be possible for a
wormhole to connect two points that are
at very different points in space a
major shortcut allowing you to reach
places across the plane faster than if
you had to go the normal route faster
than even the way that light travels
this shortcut in effect allows you to
travel faster than the speed of light
but these same bends in the fabric of
space described by Einstein's theory of
relativity could in principle also
create a wormhole connecting two
separate universes in the multiverse
I've done it I am a genius the gods a
weap as they look down upon me home here
I come but wait that that's just the
principle of how it could potentially
happen in theory in quantum physics
theory but but not actually how it
happens in practicality sure Rick's
portal gun could be creating wormholes
that connect his current point in the
fabric of space with other points in our
verse or other universes but how would
it be able to do this it must have
something to do with the portal fluid
that's what's giving it the energy or
charge that it needs to open up these
massive rifts in time and space portal
fluid obviously isn't the thing in real
life though so what in space could
potentially have enough energy for
folding the fabric of reality enough and
punching holes through it concentrated
dark matter concentrated dark matter
concentrated hot right the Galactic
Federation isn't the only group of
aliens trying to get information from
Rick's genius brain the Zygerrians are
also trying to get information from him
and what they're looking for might
actually be the same thing as what the
Galactic Federation is looking for in
the episode M night Shyamalan
concentrated dark matter is explained as
being necessary for accelerated space
travel the fuel for accelerated space
travel that makes it sound like some
kind of fuel that you'd be using to
power a spaceship but what is inner
Universal travel if not really really
accelerated travel through space using a
wormhole as a shortcut to get from one
point of space to another and whereas
Dark Matter may be full of energy
concentrated dark matter would be even
more powerful more energy dense could be
that portal fluid is just a form of dark
matter that rick has somehow been able
to harness I mean 85% of our universe is
dark matter and dark matter is the stuff
in our universe that we can observe -
it's certainly possible that this matter
unseen by us humans could have all sorts
of unusual properties properties that
could yield us limitless amounts of
energy there it is forgot my hot cocoa
Neil I figured it out the answer is
concentrated dark matter but what
exactly is dark matter can it be
concentrated and why is so much of our
universe made up of it well I'd love to
answer all those questions for you I'm
well my quantum signal is still weak at
least until I've had my morning hot
cocoa so if you and your viewers want
the recipe to Rick's secret concentrated
dark matter you're just going to have to
come over to my Startalk channel and
while they're there can you encourage
them to subscribe we're really close to
a million subscribers a number you guys
passed long ago but it'd be nice to get
that gold YouTube play button by the way
nearly all the gold in Earth's crust
came from metallic meteorites that
bombarded the planet 200
million years after it formed so your
million subscriber YouTube play button
is actually a little piece of space
hanging on your wall
very cool let's go I'll break the fourth
wall right now to encourage them to
click the box that they see on screen
right now to show our other video that
we did together all about concentrated
dark matter I'll also put a link in the
description to our video together so
they can follow us on over there watch
our video together on Rick and Morty's
dark matter and while you're over at the
start auction I'll hit the subscribe
button let's push Neil over a million
subscribers he's already almost there
and if we were able to do it for him it
would probably make him think that we're
really cool and he'd probably be more
inclined to reveal all the secrets of
the universe just for us well I'm sure
he'd probably want to reveal them to
everyone but let's just say just for us
and remember when it comes to Rick and
Morty and even some astrophysics it's
all just a theory a film theory and
hopped through the portal on screen
right now for more Rick and Morty action
with an even more dynamic duo meal and
Matt Pat
you